yeah hello welcome to a new video
something different today um that's
actually one interesting went going on
at the moment started today I wasn't
really aware that this was some
scheduled at all but the world rapids
and world blitz championship that's
about to be played or has started today
in um in Calais tan I think it's in
Astana I'm not quite sure I think a
stone on the the capital of quezacotl
Sun and yeah it's a pretty pretty strong
field it's not like all the top players
out there but yeah well it has Magnus
Carlsen in it so um you've got the world
number one and arguably the best play at
the moment playing and today they played
the first five rounds of the rapid
tournament which is a round-robin I
think with 12 players if I'm not
mistaken and yeah I'll show you briefly
those five games played today by Carlton
um let Sun get going so first round he
played black against the grandmas hmm
gosh golly f not quite sure that I
pronounce this correctly I think he's
one of the local wildcards um he left
him a couple of years in France I'm not
sure if he's back in Kazakhstan or still
has some ties to the country so well you
see his rating as three hundred points
below cousins but he was some much
higher some time ago like two six
something and it's known as a very good
blitz intrepid player so I guess it's
might might be a harder game than it
looks on paper okay let's see what
happened so Kashkari f1c formed and
magnus um as usual reply z5 he varies a
bit but usually plays d5 and we've got
an italian game or JUCO piano which
why with the classical Bishop c5 so no
Knight f6 Magnus usually plays the the
solid Bishop c5 and we see c3 Knight f6
d3 so the modern main line of the
Italian game quite a solid setup for
white which is not aimed at getting a
huge advantage but trying to maneuver
and of course this is exactly the kind
of position that cards and also it's
very good at so let's see what happens
plays d6 age three so wider miss
flexible so he hasn't castled yet and
now slide yeah I'm not quite sure if
it's a surprise or 97 is not a move that
is so well known at least to me I
usually play something like a 6 here and
Bishop a7 securing the the bishop and
then often going Bishop here to exchange
to b3 Bishop if possible so this is
another setup which I think cards and
also played before in the game he won 97
which is also interesting the idea being
to transfer the Knight to g6 where it
has good position it allows like to play
c6 and the knight on g6 always has these
options to go to f4 maybe so it's a
common regrouping and actually very
similar to good white our very often is
doing white very often goes this way and
also once have his night on g3 so black
is sort of trying to get a symmetrical
position out of this let's see what
happens wide Casa lot and he took some
time to do so so he was maybe a little
bit surprised by 97 so 96 I let me
mention the time control you see already
this is 15 minutes and I think 10 second
per move increment so
let's get going that be T to see six
very normal black wants to have the
option to play d5 at some point and also
secures a possible square for the Bishop
so deform white strikes in the center
wants to have some space advantage very
understandable retreats rocky one rookie
aid yeah and through created some
designed to make it a little bit harder
for white to play Knight f1 so he plays
Bishop here if black a white would have
tried Knight f1 which he yeah once to do
black can take and then he form is
hanging and leg wins a pawn so he cannot
go Knight f1 so we shipped it to c2h6
always useful Knight have one so now
this is possible but black is just in
time to play Knight to h5 and this is
interesting now black somewhat seems to
be somewhat quicker and getting to the
f4 Square and also the night on h5
prevents 93 so white goes now g3 you can
destroy White's pawn structure here this
is prevented one move you always need to
take into account if you play move like
Knight h5 is this move discovering on h5
in this position they'll black can can
just take here takes takes and I think
like him can be very satisfied with this
position he can maybe win tempos with
moose like you know rookie five for
Queen to h4 oops Queen to h4 stuff like
this and the bishop won't be six is
potentially very strong here so 95 is no
big deal but you need to take this into
account the not h5 is hanging in a way
so white went night to e3
keeping in mind this soups and this idea
of not this this one to f5 of course so
logical move now to a form Knight to f5
so both players are playing along
similar trains of thought queen of six
and here we arrive at the somewhat
critical position in this position white
played g3 which is a big mistake but
what happens is not so easy to see I
think of white would have played a
normal move let's say developing a piece
here then it's um maybe around equal I
don't think that there's much happening
here
both sides have got the Knights to f4 f5
+ f4 it's very solid um so maybe this is
surround equal you always tend to to
look for black advantage if you see that
cars in this black but there's just
nothing um and not easy to see how to
make progress break might play a normal
move here maybe even even go back to
support the center so not not much
happening about equal but as I mentioned
white played something else you played
g3 of course the move that that is very
interesting if you can play it I mean
it's a technical issue if like now would
retreat let's say 2 to 6 cm then white
would have gained something because the
g3 pawn just prevents black from gum
coming to have form and this is arguably
a bit better for white but of course h3
is hanging and Carlsen just took the
pawn but the point why this is possible
is not easy to spot
kingi to and now your first thought is
ok no big deal the knight is hanging
I'll just retreat to g5 but this
let's do a complete disaster
and why does outride two winning in this
position even Bishop takes g5 and rook
h1 stuff like this so this is simply
simply winning for white
so this g3 move has an idea no doubt
about it but what's happening here is on
Queen G - black doesn't need to play 9
g5 you can play the very strong move d5
and this is really really strong so what
should Y do now if you capture I'm going
to question what he played he took on e5
if white would capture on h3 here black
and taken before and then you see the
idea this d5 move really I put this
knight on f5 and a terrible pin and
black will regain his material with a
brilliant position let's say something
like this maybe there's even something
stronger something like this and like
it's a pawn up and has the much better
position because of the activity
everything is very active from legs
point of view so this is just winning on
this level at least so why does in huge
trouble here what should he do black
also simply threatening to take on e4 so
at the end he decided to play D takes d5
like just recaptures and yeah y took
here let's have a look if you take now
black and do just the same and will
regain the piece with a huge huge
position or maybe you win even more and
so much stuff hanging so not working
this is why white decided to take on e5
and black took with rook on e5 in this
position actually
here there was the posse also it was
possible to take on e4 which is a bit of
a computer move and this is even even
stronger because f2 is is also now a
threat and why it simply doesn't have a
move yeah let's say he would would move
the knight secure the night in a way and
black and just take here and grab f5
next move and you're yeah you're just
completely destroying white so this was
even even a bit bit quicker but the rook
takes d5 was certainly good enough white
no F form and the idea that Magnus he
had he plays also very nice rook takes
e4 very nicely played Bishop here and
night 2 f2 and this is a great idea
black temporarily has sacrificed the
whole rook but the f2 Knight simply Fox
those two pieces and the Queen needs to
yeah take care of herself
after which like just regained the piece
and now black simply has a clearly
better position it's got two pawns now
for the exchange and great great pieces
knight on e4 Bishop on b6 and this night
is still a pretty miserable piece he
moved it to h4 and now just Bishop d7
intending rook e8 quite logical Bishop
b3 also very understandable move you
want to get rid of this strong bishop
but this is actually met with a tactical
idea which was again very strong g5
attacking this night here and what
should I do if you take on g5 like has
simply this check here and then grabs
Erick
and the white doesn't have anything on
the king and also you've got this
immediate threat here white is just yeah
huge amount of material down here so
cannot take on g5 so I asked the knight
is hanging you don't have much choice
you need to retreat it and then like
captures on f4 and wins another pawn
yeah Queen g7 threatening on g3 very
nice yeah and what do we have at the end
four points for the exchange
quite a nice exchange sacrifice
sacrifice them you cannot really call it
so what black is now doing is he's just
advancing his material yeah here even
it's difficult to secure the rook
so why tried this kind of stuff but now
93 and in this position after rook h8
wide resigned as he will have no
alternative to what what what I actually
saw this incorrectly a white simply
doesn't have a move at all so what
should I do if he retreats the night you
can just take here and grab oops this
pawn and the night endgame with three
extra pawns I mean I mean lots of people
would win this not you don't need to be
Carlton to do this so it's just totally
lost and white resigned yeah very nice
game and it is actually this this movers
really is the star of the game this d5
the stoops this d5m swerve really strong
okay so this was the first round so it
started out with the victory let's go to
round two
which was against yeah morisevic okay
let's see what what we what we got here
Magnus you form he's varying a lot
especially in rapid place both the main
opening moves and we got a French
Morrow's old love still plays it
regularly and it's a classical variation
the steinitz line with Morel playing
Bishop e7 and yeah he's really been a
trendsetter over the years this idea
what Bishop e7 s an old favorite of
morals he plated I think back in the 90s
even really a long time ago and it
nowadays sort of became one of the main
lines were like is searching for new
ideas and not without success actually
ideas to stay flexible with this move
you have multiple options later white
plays at Queen d2 he's got some
alternatives of course and now b6 and
this is a quite interesting setup this
b6 move actually prevents white from
taking ever taking on c5 as you would
play be c5 and have a huge center and
you see em what happens in the game this
is the idea that black is following
let's put a couple of moves on the board
they're pretty pretty logical
anyway black plays f6 here and this is
the kind of position that black is
aiming for he wants to have this
opportunity maybe using the four square
and one idea even might be to put the
bishop on b7 also supporting the snide
to e form so this is a really
interesting kind of strategical game
like a seaming form actually am this
variation also was used by Magnus
himself as black against vasila even
shock for a nice win last year I think
in the Masters
I'm not mistaken so um King edge one
white one no it's a very common move
f-fine King edge one to get rid of any
possible checks I'm black when c4 and
this is a very committal move of course
but according to the the plan here
because Bishop before now really fights
for the e4 square like aiming now to
play an idea form and it's quite
interesting what happens here
ninety-five like takes D takes d5 and 94
in the first at first you think okay
black must be must be doing great here
his realized all his ideas but it's not
so clear cut white 194 now 94 a black
194 White Queen e1 and in this position
of course um black has some alternatives
what he played is the very direct move
deform I'm not sure if this is really
good he had some alternatives of course
he could have captured on c3 for
instance and this really makes this
super strong piece only form or black
now might try as to play for this kind
of maneuver if black matches this he's
certainly very okay um white of course
is not without ideas also he could play
something like Bishop here to secure
this point and then maybe even try to
prepare this kind of pawn storm would be
very complex
um position but quite a good alternative
for black I guess um we we it was we had
I don't know let's say a risky in d4 is
really risky because it opens up the
position and
not so great developed rookie Vanya is
what what was played now maybe a black
player Amoroso which have miscalculated
something it doesn't lead to a terrible
position for black and I don't want to
give this impression it just leads to a
position where wider certainly happy to
to play um yeah like it's in a pin now
and I don't think he has much choice he
took on c3 now B takes on c3 Bishop and
Queen f2 and this is really nice white
now intends to get the pawn back so I'm
black played b5 an alternative here was
ready to take here play this kind of
position this is quite similar to the
game and the issue in this structure is
simply this point in this square on d6
white always has this idea to put a rook
on d6 and it's very hard for black to
tolerate this kind of piece on d6 but if
you take white will have opportunities
to get a strong passer here and use we
see is quite similar structure in the
game in the game b5 yeah this is quite
similar
still this d6 square and now we see
Bishop f3 rook was the Czech needs to
move and rook t1 note that Carlton
absolutely doesn't care about the H upon
black played Bishop here
let's check wickley what happens if
black would take then rook e8 is is
exceptionally exceptionally strong move
um what should should like do now let's
say he retreats then white can take
and play this move and this is very
strong look here and this is also
hanging white white is winning in this
position let's say look Bishop e7 and
then you can just take here with this
idea yeah like black simply loses he
cannot take on a2 and this position
already is a very dangerous for black he
has problems
oops I need to use this button here he
has problems with his bishop cannot go
here and while this move is I think what
he played and we see what happens white
gets on the seventh rank yeah and white
now is quite quite a lot better here the
seventh rank and the D form and the c6
pawn is so also a weakness it's hard to
tell how how bad this is for black but
no question is that why does got a huge
advantage and tries to put much pressure
on black very uncomfortable to play
so when rook the 8th and hope to 6 this
is what I mentioned black cannot really
take this for this rook went here and
now white tries to use the Queen rook e7
yeah black am had some alternatives this
is of course a position which is yam
pretty much pure calculation so what
about this year maybe black hood could
go here try and for counter play this is
also very tricky let's say here and what
should like do now if you go here white
can just take
yeah and this doesn't end well made to
come so if you cannot play rock f7 you
only have this move and then white can
actually take here we cause this again
gets checkmated in a couple of moves
black can take here covering g6 and this
is the kind of position which you simply
cannot calculate not even those guys I
guess yeah hard to tell what's happening
here now this rook might move maybe here
okay I don't want to do a for our video
here very complicated maybe black had
had better chance with Quincy 3 but he
went
Ruki 7 and now white could could take
the pawn and he did so yeah I'm like
trying to get some counter play here g3
and now Queen e2 this was his idea
but the issue is this e pawn is simply
very very fast now
a5 rook here and now d6 coming I am Not
sure I think this is not possible to
defend here f5 is also nice little
tactical shot if black would take now
you play here
yeah and this is yeah made in a couple
of moves this is a very nice one with
the rook on e7 taking away the the
squares I'm not quite sure what my
computer is doing here
what's happening
somehow I have this kind of Windows
symbol going here
not sure what is doing all right so he
couldn't take on f5 and he played Queen
a3 and why just grabbed here also
covering this one f5 yeah I think this
is just a matter of good technical play
now
yeah I'm black skin position is also a
problem very loose King here
yeah and now we see white trying to use
some blacks King position immediately
like rapped and now this very strong
move threatening rook here and yeah what
should like do if he moves the King then
you've got this check coming yeah right
here you absolutely cannot cover g6
amazing if you go here it's a made in
one move so very very much of a problem
and some of our computer has a problem
if there's a checkmate here funny not
quite sure what's happening I tried to
to press the the button which just takes
back a move and it somehow doesn't do
anything
checkmate seems to irritate the computer
ok so let me try this button again to to
get back to the main line it's quite
annoying actually
ok so moral took here on only 6 and rock
G form King edge 8 and yeah it's a
basically what I just what I just showed
and it's curtains made on g7 off all
this kind of move just not not too
problematic guy from 4matic also yeah so
very nice win in the end I think really
crucial was what's the situation around
here this kind of position which
happened with the rook here invading was
was very problematic for black maybe he
could have defended better but not a
very very fruitful task somehow ok this
was second game and the second win the
round after that I think was was the
sweet lamb not quite sure
yeah against Peter sweetly all right so
cards are playing black and Spitler
played C form interesting his uh yeah an
e4 player from back from his childhood
but in recent yes he tried to branch out
a bit so I'm also interesting that
sweetly here okay
he wanted to stay along English lines he
could have played d44 trying to get into
a king's indian or Marazzi point but
okay we stay within English territory
and Magnus plays Knight h6 he am played
this kind of setup before wants to go
here to control the default square let's
just put a couple of moves on the board
yeah here's wiggler played the
interesting move be formed I think most
people here would have maybe played
rugby one to prepare this move but
Sevilla here shows that you can play it
without this preparation if now black
would take with the pawn you can just
take here and then white I think would
most likely just play d4 I don't know if
this is a theoretical position it's just
what I was thinking because now White
has quite a nice center and it's
questionable what these Knights are
doing there maybe just getting kicked
around with moves like this or if or and
I don't know I think white should have
some decent compensation magnets played
something else he took with the knight
also an interesting maneuver because
here black uses the pin so he will get
some material back y24
black took and now he formed and now we
see that in return for some sacrifice of
yeah even two pawns at the moment white
has build up this great center here
night here yeah h6 also wasn't great and
Queen to d3
so it's interesting in this position now
I think cards in place quite strong move
and I think this is the kind of move
which a strong player immediately
recognizes as something which you might
need to do really have to do because if
you play some sort of young passive move
yeah let's say black plates plays a
passive move then it's it's really
questionable what happens now here if
you go here your knight is very much
offside this is also just a terrible
square and white white has huge
compensation so to make it short what
cards of lady is b5 immediately I'm
giving back and pawn and this way
opening up the position wider took it
alternative would be maybe c5 and then
like actually can enter on c4 in this
Knight from being a sort of hunted
animal it just developed into a pretty
strong beasts on C form so no idea to
play c5 on white captured on b5 then
Queen b6 and now you see that black will
regain on b5 upon most likely and in the
process also activate this Knight Bishop
a3 pretty pretty logical move Queen b5
and white of course didn't want to trade
at the moment
Bishop a6
you know maybe black also could could
have played here very complicated
position but you need to note that black
is two pawns up yam and I think it's
hard to believe that there shouldn't be
um yes somewhat better for black I mean
two points you can yeah you will lose
some one pawn most likely at some point
multi three most likely or maybe a seven
or something but then you'll still would
have an extra pawn so it should be it
should be nice for black this position
okay when Bishop a 6u5 attacking the
knight and g4 very concrete play by Sid
lung
if black now retreats the night then
white could could take on e7 and I think
there should be quite nice for white to
put it to put it mildly you still have
this ridiculous night out so this one is
close to being gone so this is bad so
what else is there he took on the form
and 25 yeah and now black has seven
points white only three so black has got
four points four piece this this piece
is saying though
so if white would for instance take the
rook now black can take on d4 and you've
got g4 hanging at f1 hanging this is
also a threat of course that black has
just taking the rook so white plate look
after the one securing the rook and
protecting the form rook c8 yeah the
bishop went back to attack a six
oops didn't want to do that I'm sorry
Bishop c1 Bishop c4 and look at seven so
wide regained upon blacks it has got
three pawns for the piece I think this
is all pretty logical and now black
tries to him to use the C pawn therefore
white goes f4 and still e5 activating
the pieces
yeah I think this is all pretty pretty
understandable why it got c3 back and
now it's just two points yeah well I can
play actively here of course checking on
H 2 root 2 G 3
I cannot go here because this one is
saying we'll check out so so rook G 3
makes me makes much sense
Ruka 8 yeah the idea to invade here yeah
Black has a very active position still
so easy no big danger of losing I think
yeah white sacrifice in exchange back
but in return he got a very nice grip
here on the dark square deform and you
will see that white manages to
coordinate very nicely here after the
Queen exchange this bishop transformed
into a really monster deform and you can
see that this diagonal is quite strong
white um fixes the pawns here and now
just once to transfer his Knight
yeah actually I already have highlighted
the squares white would like to get a
knight to h6 f6 something like this also
f4 would have been a nice square so we
see that is this kind of regrouping now
like gave away the pawn here and now
we've got this kind of idea yeah White
has discovered checks but they don't
lead to too much
yeah of course in this position but now
why does the only only one who can try a
little bit trying to gain the two two
two to win one of those pawns and he an
interesting move rook the eight which
pretty much is the kind of yeah show me
move and show me this I mean and white
played this looks like a blunder at
first sight from like but it has got an
idea exactly this idea like now
attacking g5 and white cannot cover the
pawn really we go king f4 you have to
check here and then get the pawn so
white um went back with the knight rook
g5 and I think this position should be a
draw really the thing is that rook and
Knight were this rook is it's a draw and
white only has got got this gg3 pawn and
it's simply not possible to win all
three black pawns for nothing and keep
the g3 pawn so he tried tried a bit a
couple of moves but it was most drawn
pretty very quickly yeah white simply
cannot make any progress the the issue
is some here that like has these moves
this no no no no not now but H form and
white simply cannot make any progress
this King is also very safe yeah so I'm
a pretty interesting draw actually um
and yeah good fight good fight this game
you see that you can really get
interesting position even out of
somewhat dry looking openings okay
fourth game cards are played five games
today I'm I'm only on the fourth one so
it's already a long video
what is was interesting chess really
really
so our next game like has Victor Borge
on long-term top player in the top 100
range who recently made a huge leap to
really big rating year 2730 and Bulldog
and as a player I really recommend her
to follow because he's very enterprising
interesting player is uh um tries to
yeah play active interesting aggressive
chess so it's something to watch
okay so let's see what happened Colin
playing yeah c4 he's varying his
openings and Bulldog on c6 offering a
transposition to to a pun off Carrick on
which actually something that Magnus
could play but didn't happen he just
transpose into the Slav and Mulligan
played Bishop f5 got this slows laughs
at e3 and now a six which is yeah
kind of understandable because this is a
mixture between the slow Slav and the
cheapening Kozlov was a six this chevon
ankle line is of course really dear to
to the black player's heart yes Siobhan
ankle was his trainer mentor and young
and inventor of lots of opening ideas
that bull agon used throughout his
career
um bolo gun also wrote a book on this a6
stuff the a6 line in the Slav and
Chevron ankle line okay so why doesn't
really try to refute it he just develops
h6 retreating square secured so that
this kind of idea can always be answered
by Bishop age seven and now contemplate
Queen b3 and rookie at seven which has
some one of the ideas actually after say
six move to have this this pretty yeah
non-standard way of defending b7 but
very often this is not such a big deal
later the rookin
be regrouped after this pawn is secured
in another way some white took now and
just played Bishop d2 and this looks at
first very innocuous here but no white
white um certainly has a slight
advantage in development he's ready to
castle already while black has played a
couple of questionable moves in terms of
development and it's quite quite strange
what happens here actually black play
see six very normal looking move white
plays some Knight to e5 and now black
plays Bishop d6
and this is pretty and pretty amazing
alternative was just there should be
seven and I have my doubts that white
really can play for something big here
and most likely you would Castle and
possible ideas for white of course
something like Roxy one you could also
try this kind of maneuver Knight to a4
looking at those squares and also
intending Bishop two before exchanging
the dark squared bishop
I mean white as maybe it's very slightly
better but it's not a position that a
Slav player should lose too much sleep
about I think at least with this brief
time that I had to look at at this but
in the game he played Bishop to d6
which was answered by not a queen to a
forum and this is some yeah a bit of an
embarrassment now what should black play
if he plays b5 yeah there's a knight b5
and yeah like loses instantly cannot go
b5
and a few plays a move like this here
then sense though might be five and you
see that these two pieces are really
yeah and a pretty unlucky configuration
so what should black play if he goes
here you know the song remains the same
kingi seven maybe so this move and what
is blacks supposed to do if he retreats
then this is well not really worthy of a
world blitz a blue world rapid a
championship yeah but what what should
like do this is just the same it's
always tough Bishop Knight b5 so he
decided on knight c6 at the end and yeah
wah no rocket science here white took on
c6 and just one upon yeah so this Bishop
d6 was just a miscalculation and some
sort of some sorts yeah black Queen d7
here
yeah and white now has some yeah has an
extra pawn it's um
yeah mildly challenging technically I
mean the the thing is white will will
have this idea looking at those squares
and this Knight f4 also always secures
this somewhat soft spot on b2 like
simply doesn't have any
yeah really concrete play here we'll see
that black tries to get something
yeah but now this is just this is just
yeah basically over with the Carlton's
technique it's um it's just over why
this has got the extra poem the better
porn structure and Blake doesn't have
anything concrete going for him so why
just slowly but steadily improve the
position yeah like suffers from those
weaknesses white also has got the
potentially a better Bishop here looking
at this d5 square so let's follow this
and Carlton's technique is usually very
very good yeah
and now the final chapter in the story
White's King needs to be involved
improving the the peace here
no hurry very important
why does all the time in the world
Hey
I wonder was it really necessary to do
it at this point let's see what happens
I didn't really look so much at this
game I pretty much after the opening
thought okay this is an extra point he
will win this but is this so clear-cut
here
hmm yeah we didn't rotate it here
because I didn't really prepare this
game because I thought okay this is
winning anyway but looking at this now
I'm not I'm not too sure of course
okay white couldn't take of course let's
start with the simple stuff and the a
pawn promotes so it's clear that this
was the idea so like here
b6
mm yeah switch on the switch the engine
on the engine actually gives this is
almost equal which is quite shocking to
me this is what will blow gun plate and
this losers yeah okay okay what's down
to ten seconds also but the computer
actually gives this amazing move and
says and just assesses this is equal
right D seven okay and this is supposed
to be equal got to be kidding me
now black black has some activity I'm no
doubt about it I just show that the main
line of the computer right don't want to
do an hour longer analysis here do you
form and say here
no this might might be even tricky for
Wyatt hmm
check
yeah like it's very active here
if you go here then D and F pawn
actually win so here
oh yeah I can believe this this is a
draw yeah well the computer is just yeah
without any mercy in this kind of
position so here black actually could
have drawn I'm a bit cautious still but
with 98 but with no time on the clock
possible so white so Magnus um was a bit
too too quickly in allowing this kind of
simplification but okay it's a it's a
rapid game all right so so some chance
missed here bye-bye below gone but it
happens it's rapid it's not
correspondence chess okay and so um
let's then switch to the last game here
of course this was on long game again
against Grandmaster cool loose off I'm
not quite sure why he is participating
it's not so high rated um maybe he did
want some cool we did win some qualify
or something possible not quite sure
okay so cards and black we've got a rule
of pass and he actually goes for the
Berlin no fear to play this for Windows
black corrosive castled takes and now he
played rookie one which is yeah sort of
the spoilsport line here which doesn't
even allow the Berlin endgame which
arguably is not it's not so easy to play
even for white rookie won 96 95 this is
White's idea and you see what this leads
to there should be seven to block the ad
form of course just to show it could
yeah like cannot grab here as this wins
about everything here so um there should
be 7s
tried-and-tested move white drops the
bishop back and get this kind of
position which has some slight
resemblance to an exchange French the e
line opened here and this is I think
what what basically has been White's
idea wants to exchange quite a number of
pieces and maybe get get a draw
so let's um put some moves on the bottom
to not make this video such a long
affair it's already much longer than I
have blend blend blend it to be so white
is basically trying to activate his
pieces and exchange some stuff along the
lines yeah this kind of position here
certainly as some yeah somewhat better
for white I guess the active pieces so
not much to worry about
so we exchanged a couple of pieces here
yeah it goes to the endgame and um yeah
it's very hard to imagine that this
shouldn't end in the draw but actually
it didn't end in a draw you can you can
guess what happened at the end okay I
think one issue in this position
possibly is this kind of poor
information here like say for porn
blocks those two phones and he's got
this nice c4 idea and somehow black
managed to really make something out of
this
yeah not much happening really
yeah sort of maneuvering yeah this is
some of course oops hit this this bloody
button again which wants five moves you
have cause this kind of maneuver is
something which always needs to be
taking into account using the rook here
on the fifth rank off sometimes it's
also like this to check this weakness
very good useful maneuver one should
really take note of really happens often
yeah I think I'm still objectively
there's not much happening but let's see
how it continues this regrouping now
possibly allows to take the knight yeah
black put the rock back not much left
for it to do
yeah and this is an important point here
in the game white cannot now just pass
him if you would would play a move like
this then you need to also reckon with
this kind of stuff
oops not h3 attacking h4 and this is
second weakness in addition to this pawn
so um white needs to take this into
account and captures well Iran TM black
is definitely starting to maybe get a
little something but it's hard to say
at which point that really gets critical
maybe I should have white could have
stayed stayed to put here just rook to 2
f2 and maybe trying to also maybe try
something like this here what he did he
captured here and then like entered on
only 2 not quite sure if this is so if
this is a good idea yeah I played look
to f2 not sure can you go here
you have the problem is that this pawn
also now becomes a weakness still this
looks um looks playable for white yeah
in the game he he offered to exchange
looks and
this was his idea trying to get to b5
yeah and black now still has this idea
of night c4 to a three but he wants to
use the rook at the King saw his rook
the King to check this night and then
grab a three
Wow this is really cool move kingi to
mom yeah
what white white could have played
simply this move here
attacking also this engine then drop
here this idea also the thing is in the
game he played the game via King e2 and
and look at this white Schneider simply
simply trapped because these squares are
taken by its own pawns and everything
else is covered by blacks pieces so King
it - a tragic mistake here and he still
had 40 seconds or something on the clock
yeah maybe some sort of hallucination
you don't really is what at first that
the knight has so uh so little squares
yeah when this one wouldn't have lost
the game for sure so white really for a
long time had the drawing position so
let's let's just continue this a bit
here something like this
and we'll just get everything will get
exchanged here something like this yeah
that draw but he he unfortunately didn't
give the check but went here to King he
- yeah
king ii ii ii ii basically blunder this
night all right so good lucky in the end
um for for Magnus um he had this were
five games today and yeah you just go
off four and a half points a bit of luck
iam at the end so should have been four
maybe but it also yeah
pays off to be persistent and always
press on than those kind of mistakes
happening are happening yeah thanks for
watching I think I'll have time tomorrow
to do a do a second part of this to wrap
up the tourney so to say
Magnus no huge favorite I guess with
four and a half points but he is only
shared first I think saga Sega coyoacán
also only considered draw so couple of
interesting games hope you enjoyed it
and I guess I'll be back tomorrow with
the second half of this tournament
choice and talk to you soon